cause I'm in it alone and I was betrayed
so things are very real yeah that that
that's exactly the that was exactly my
thought I was like here's a here's
here's a guy who's operating on his own
terms like he's eating
his whole life and uh and now he's
not anymore no he's saying you're gonna
eat my mm-hmm yeah love it Warren
Thompson with the cosmic Wonder Kingsley
I
after the first two episodes well after
the first one I was already hooked just
completely hooked and your character I
love your character he's not a typical
villain he's yes he's capable yes he's
intimidating we've seen how capable he
is after you know the first two episodes
but there is trauma behind him so what
is the core emotion for you you know for
this quote-unquote villain here what is
the core emotion that you're portraying
when you're playing him
uh I'm not so
the core emotion you never set out to
play the emotion but I I think the
feeling is his feelings are definitely
like uh
to do with rage and uh rage that has
turned into hatred for for Fury and
chaos and I think it's the
the feeling of uh hypocrisy sits strong
in him you know oh that their hypocrisy
right is what enrages him
um
so yeah I'd say rage hatred and
hypocrisy were like some key words that
kept popping up for me
um but he's he's also doing this
for his people as well that's that was
my question coming up is it seems like
that but is he blind now is it has it
become about it I think he needs the
people around him to think that that's
what's going on ah but I think what's
operating underneath for the show needed
to be very different you know otherwise
I feel like yeah I think there needed to
be multiple layers going on
um love that yeah I don't think he
trusts anyone well and that's a great
part about the shows on both sides
nobody knows who they can trust and
that's very apparent and I've I've that
sort of uh ambiguity of the show I
really really love but that's great that
you said that because I think it's very
real I think a lot of people can get
you know untrusting and then just blind
by rage and you say I have to do all
this myself for myself and I'm doing
what I want because I'm in it alone and
I was betrayed so things are very real
yeah that that that's exactly the that
was exactly my thought I was like here's
a his here's a guy who's operating on
his own terms like he's eating
his whole life and uh and now he's
not anymore no he's saying you're gonna
eat my yeah love it and that's what
makes him a great villain you have a new
villain right that you get to create
here yeah so did you did you study other
villains of the MCU other other villains
of other movies or any real life you
know maybe villains to to me I guess I
tried not to think of him as a villain
just as like I tried to
to think about
like real examples of people who get to
that place where they they can
they can like they can project that kind
of violence
um
or the completely desensitized to it or
like who feel no emotion around murder
or
um who can blow up a town square with
small children in it and reveal nothing
and I I think what was interesting
without having any Comics to go from and
just looking at the text was that at the
end of that first episode there was
something about
Graphics need for Fury to see him
do it and how he toys with him how he
how he's playing with them because he
that felt like there was a real need for
gravic to have Talos and fury in those
situations as they were happening which
for me was
that was the layer that I was that
that's the script based information that
we have to hold on to here like that's
like
that's really specific that's the kind
of detail that I didn't I wanted to hold
on to
um
yeah and you go well you hope that kind
of thing is what's going to make him
feel complicated and right but more
scary or uh more dangerous I think it's
about what and I think it that really
does come across because even with you
know your line
could have killed him right and in the
scene you very well could have the
character very well could have but going
back to what you said about almost like
something to prove like you've been
betrayed and now you want to show Stick
it to him right and it's like oh I'm not
just gonna just go out and like kill him
I'm gonna kind of torture him and part
of that is making him watch what I can
do yeah I always had an issue with that
line that line kept me really a few
nights yeah when he says that uh to Gaia
because I was like
I didn't see him really as a like a
show-off the lamb was a little cocky and
I was like so and and sometimes you get
lands because they're right and as you
go you go how do you make this work
his line and I think that again anyone
who's who's around him whether it's
Pagan or guy or those Scrolls he's just
I was like he just has to be toying with
people and teasing them and testing them
and uh
everything is about I I just don't think
he cares for anyone so I don't really
that land I was like why is he saying
this
okay it's funny because that land that
was one lane I was like oh I don't know
if this feels right but it's in so yeah
and your character is fantastic I I
truly can't wait to see his Arc and what
happens after this because I'm just
hooked I really am right so
congratulations thank you so much for
the time today
absolutely thank you